so you guys have three options we have
just regular questions from the fans
wanting to ask we have unhelpful advice
questions and a lot of people have a lot
of MMA questions we have not touched
anything why not I feel so sad about it
because I've so much to say about MMA
but we'll do MMA last okay because that
way they can you know well let's start
with the regular just a regular fan
question okay someone asked on Twitter
dude oh god there's so much Margaret
stuff now I have to go through it worst
Christmas guests gift ever received
mine was a bookmark with a magnifying
lens I was 13 years kalila worst uh
worst I go Bobby first I can't even
think of one his was his pillow I think
well here's the worst gift I ever gave
someone for Christmas yeah is so but
when I was dating you know Sarah I was
dating this comet named sarah hyland
yeah and she's from Louisville Kentucky
and her parents were in LA for a
Christmas and um I I got her a gift I
forgot what it was but it wasn't
something that she wanted like I could
tell she was it was like underwhelming
so I just thought I got I need said I
need to give her something else so I
have a surprise for you and so in my
closet in a box
I had this vintage painting like cool
like it was like unicorn you know like
she loves unicorns and she's like that
so I wrapped it and what her
parents were at my house I was living
above the comedy store and I gave it to
her and she opened it and she goes oh I
go Merry Christmas another gift I got
for you she goes I gave you this last
year
damn man and her parents are there and
it wasn't funny what is your problem and
everyone was like everyone was like like
looking at me like no it wasn't no it
wasn't funny because it was really
embarrassing
I think that
a friend of mine gave me some bogus like
an enlarged safety pin and she was like
well this means this and this means that
and she was getting all philosophical
and like no you just broke and
you're giving me a safety pin you're
trying to add meaning you know mmm that
was probably the worst one cuz I didn't
buy into what it would she said it meant
and I'm like God could you have just
gotten me like a protein bar or
something a safety pin so that that was
probably my worst one I felt like she
was frontin like it was something my
worst one was something I asked for but
I was just trying to say it out loud so
I looked like I was tough like I was
everyone was into paintball at the time
yeah so I got a paintball gun and that's
all I got and I hate paintball
Chrissy and I got pegged by
paintball so I never I should would pay
Paul I just asked for it because he
thought it was cool yeah so like
everyone saw the other people going to
him I was like CDF stupid I never used
it stupid gift
[Music]